and topping already with rebound number
five
knox aggressive right back to top and
beautiful setup from a couple of
young nick forwards the analytics up by
seven
here's top and handling that ball
outside under control not out of control
and then knox returns the favor and
there you see
some of the athleticism high flying
finish
just explosive
i like this because he's got to make
some that's what he is
stanley's a really a really good athlete
well he can keep three balling mike
he'll have an opportunity
topping throws it out too quickly fires
to dennis smith smith drives inside nice
feed the top and there's excellent ball
movement there
look at him directing traffic now throws
it up for topping yeah
beautiful connection the two-first
having an auspicious garden debut
dishing and swishing topping hopping
that time along the baseline
let's take a look at the neophytes
getting it on number one pick
again you would as sometimes hooping by
barrett as well
barrett to tapping for the slam
beautiful set up
and the knicks go up by seven with 31
seconds remaining
and this time the left face
mcconnell probes the defense the former
76 great cut
cash is stanley reads that his teammate
is in trouble
and he makes a great cut good first half
here
in this last preseason game and
philadelphia back the other way
scott bradley milton
good defense
and stanley has his second dunk much
better much deeper team
depth showing up a little bit uh of a
problem here
oh yeah what a pass and a dunk by
stanley
you know that's why you get paid so
whether they're no fans or capacity
crowd you got to get up and do it
olly from brashdakish to toppin
first 20-point lead of the season for
the warriors in his own now
anthony simons attacking that stone wow
simon's got all the way to the ring what
is this
i'm not sure [ __ ] the tips about that
one
quickly throws it up and chop and throws
it down
and then here's quickly throwing it up i
like him
i like quickly a lot makes great
decisions so brad stevens has never had
50 through three quarters
wow that's what ob topping can do
good hands good finisher nick's on
offense
pick-and-roll yeah peyton pritchard
when you switch got to get underneath on
that play he'll be topping all the way
to the basket for the dunk
has been able to shoot the ball very
well today
yep it's been a struggle i'll be topping
on a beautiful alley
from emmanuel quickly but watch the
exquisite pass by iq
and the slam they did a few of those
last
yesterday as well in boston a little
more pep in this step
swarming defense back in the zone
quickly sets up top it for the emphatic
slam
yeah along the left baseline with their
biggest lead of the night
the top in former dayton flyer
can't allow their zone to take them out
of their continuity
the block by burks on wadabaker
blocked a three-point attempt the well
for top and another slam
top very inhospitable tonight against
penetrators and shooters allowing the
knicks to get in transition
watch top and feeling in lane with gusto
and able to show his stuff see topping
post up there he's got haliburton on it
not a good shot but toppings follows
topic
the knicks are three for nine the trend
into the game
only ten points we mentioned even
playing pulley
as top and throws it down on a nice feed
from
[Applause]
17-5 run for okc
simons goes baseline
whoa anthony off the right
leg oh my goodness
look at this facial expression doesn't
even change his hand is his business
well his father mike from his father one
of the first black players in the sec
was the first at lsu yep nice feed there
and i'll be topping big stuff
and topping giving the knicks some good
minutes today
gibson finds a cutting obi topping who
slams it down
in the fourth corner yeah topping
hopkins
with the two-handed slam and he was the
most improved player in the g league got
that award
rose splits the defense back to chopping
for the slam and one
gets inside he's slamming and jamming
so rose slicing and dicing top and
hopping for the stuff and he will shoot
one as well how
sweet it is robinson with eight points
seven rebounds in the first quarter
right of the season's averages
robinson got a piece of that one yeah
rose finds topping all alone underneath
now that's what he averages on the
season
topping previously bacon and thank you
mitchell robinson with his ninth rebound
up to your erratic shooting here's
topping on the feed from rose
yeah he had a mismatch that time has
been posting and toasting had smith on
him this time
yeah that caused one of the reasons that
caused their demise the other reason
they didn't come to play they waited too
late
knox to chop it who slams it home
the dayton flyer 6-9
verizon with a master blaster
so nice we'll show it twice
yeah he's more shaky
goes right at top and top it looked like
he took it away from him excellent
defensive play from the rookie
yep baseball not protecting the ball
with his body
and then getting out in transition
burke's finding him with a marvelous avi
alley-oop
fox drives keeps his dribble alive and
throws it hits the bottom of the
backboard
nilokina
[Applause]
[Applause]
doing a good job finding them on the
week disagree with them
bursts to noelle well nice feet in and
it'll be topping with a quick jam
and the knicks back up by four let's
take a look at the dunk
by topping
so jackson and encore so nice we sure
twice
but nobody remembers that obviously with
what wilt did
nice feet ahead and i'll be tapping able
to knock it down
well this is getting ready for the slam
dunk he certainly has the athleticism
that was uh let's see what was i at that
time i was
i was 10 months old with something
creative
yeah the tomahawk that time
statue of liberty this time